über ihr leben als muslime in
deutschland zeichnet zu feiner hamed
comics frech und mit viel humor erzählt
sie von vorurteilen und klischees
ob das dann eigentlich dann irgendwann
mal mehr gemacht als andere kinder
vielleicht weil ich mehr spaß daran
gefunden habe und deshalb eigentlich
schon seit ich klein bin ich habe vor
vier fünf jahren angefangen meine bilder
ins internet zu stellen
und ich hab dann einmal ein bild
hochgeladen und zwar ein bild das einen
muslim fühle mich in der u bahn zeigt
und ich sehe eine ältere dame die da
nämlich an starten
im zweiten panel sieht man die situation
aus der sicht der älteren frau und dem
schießstand der kaufdruck schranken
muslime ein alien da das war eine
erfahrung die die eigentlich alle
muslime einem muslimischen frauen mit
kopftuch teilen die medien sondern
alltag für die psychologie studentin zu
feiern haben
sie ist in tunesien geboren in berlin
aufgewachsen gläubig seitdem sie zwölf
ist trägt sie ein kopftuch freiwillig
das provoziert nach wie vor die
deutschland weglassen und aufnahmen zu
geben
doch auch die 23-jährige hat vorurteile
auch das thema in ihren bildern die auf
der internetplattform traffics wird die
wind art dot com zu sehen sind
wir sind genauso menschen dieses
psychologische phänomen das die leute
kategorisieren wollen ist auch bei
muslimen
also wir neigen dazu einfach leuten
etwas in den mund zu legen oder in den
gedanken und die dann gar nicht
vorkommen und die dann einfach gleich so
eine distanz aufbauen also die frauen
auf der linken seite denkt sich aldi
guckt mich an die hast bestimmt muslime
und die auf der rechten seite denkt ja
die gucken mich an die hast bestimmt
nicht muslime genau diese distanz und
missverständnisse sind es die so feiner
hamid mit ihren bildern überbrücken will
dabei geht es nicht nur um den islam
oder das kopftuch sondern einfach um den
ganz normalen alltag
also ich glaube bilder sprechen menschen
viel schneller an als texte und wir
können sie auch viel schneller
wahrnehmen und gerade bilder kann man
viel humor und mit übertreibungen
arbeiten und ich glaube ein gutes stück
nur gute portion humor ist ganz wichtig
um ängste und mauern einzureißen
immer wieder wird sie gefragt warum sie
das kopftuch trägt trage aus ganz
persönlichen gründen weil es für mich
ein teil meiner region ist und ich mich
dadurch stärker fiel und auch sicherer
vor allem zu meinem in meiner beziehung
zu gott
mittlerweile hat sie eine riesige
fangemeinde wenige bilder touren im
moment auf einer wanderausstellung durch
deutschland um selbst bundespräsident
joachim gauck ist begeistert von ihrem
zeichnungen inhalt besonders gut
gefallen dass ich sagte dass man aus
zwei verschiedenen perspektiven manchmal
was ganz anderes lied und wahrnimmt und
dass es auf beiden seiten extrem gibt
und dass es ihm anscheinend hängen
geblieben
man will zeigen ganz alltägliche dinge
und ich hoffe dass leute sich darin
wieder ecken egal ob sie ein kopftuch
tragen denn nicht und dadurch erkennen
dass das irgendwie alle gleich sind
ob muslime sind oder nicht
nein